luisa volkhausen ist in münchen an der
theresienwiese hier ist um 16 uhr ging
es los mit der hauptkundgebung kannst du
uns erzählen was es bisher in münchen
passiert ja der demo tag hier ist heute
um 12 uhr gestartet am odeonsplatz da
mit dem vorausgegangen ist ein längeres
hin und her letzten tagen erst heute
früh in aller herrgottsfrühe heute
morgen hat der bayerische
verwaltungsgerichtshof entschieden dass
die demonstration beziehungsweise ein
demonstrationszug am odeonsplatz starten
darf die stadt hatte das vorher
untersagt ursprünglich angemeldet war
ein demonstrationszug mit 5000
teilnehmern vom odeonsplatz zur
theresienwiese
das wurde dann untersagt letztlich wie
gesagt heute morgen in aller frühe
erlaubt wurde der demonstrationszug mit
500 teilnehmern vom odeonsplatz zur
theresienwiese
der zug wurde dann aber auch beendet
aber tatsächlich wurde er von den
veranstaltern selber beendet
vorausgegangen waren diverse hinweise
der polizei dass die maske nicht alle
die massen pflicht nicht eingehalten
wurde die abstände wurden nicht
eingehalten
statt der erlaubten 500 teilnehmer
sollen etwa 3000 demonstranten haben und
der uns platzt sich eingefunden haben
und von da los gezogen sein
jetzt sind wir hier auf der
theresienwiese hier ist die zweite
veranstaltung ja und luisa wir sehen
auch hinter dir ist was los da sind noch
recht viele menschen unterwegs wie wird
es da jetzt weiter gehen kannst du uns
einen ausblick geben
aktuell ist es soweit ruhig man das kann
man das kann man wohl sagen also
zwischendurch das waren
polizeihubschrauber im einsatz hat die
veranstaltung von oben überwacht es gab
dann den hinweis dass die abstände teils
nicht eingehalten wurden daraufhin wurde
die veranstaltung auch hier kurzzeitig
unterbrochen ist jetzt aber fortgesetzt
es ist weitestgehend ruhig zwischendurch
werden demonstranten von der polizei
abgeführt die polizei geht jetzt durch
die menge kontrolliert immer die
einhaltung der massen pflicht das
spricht die demonstranten gezielt und
einzeln an
wenn leute dann abgeführt werden wird
das tatsächlich von vielen buhrufen
begleitet also teils beleidigungen gegen
die polizei aber so weit kann man sagen
ist es ruhig bis 19.30 ist die
veranstaltung noch angemeldet und
scheint auch bis dahin stattzufinden
luisa volkhausen aus münchen so lange
wirst du für uns natürlich auch vor ort
bleiben und sollte irgendetwas passieren
dann erfahren sie dass alle hier auch
bei uns auf bild.de
mehr nachrichten um breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren